es el segundo intento para destituir a
pedro castillo quien justo hoy cumple 8
meses en el poder el presidente de perú
se enfrenta a una moción de vacancia que
el congreso de mayoría opositora
presentó en su contra castilho niega
todas las acusaciones y en las últimas
semanas ha enfocado sus esfuerzos en
obras públicas y no en los señalamientos
de la oposición
[Música]
el domingo cientos de personas salieron
a las calles para apoyar la medida que
el congresista de ultraderecha jorge
montoya impulsó con otros partidos en
contra del gobierno la oposición
argumenta tres investigaciones por
corrupción en su contra señalan que el
mandatario ha mentido en investigaciones
fiscales así como de supuestas
irregularidades en ascensos militares y
policiales por su parte la defensa del
presidente peruano ha pedido que la oea
haga presencia en el parlamento al
momento de la votación
tiene que apoyar la bancada
porque la patria está en peligro en
manos
no solamente cero
para que la destitución del presidente
pase se necesita el apoyo de 87 de los
130 miembros del legislativo de ser
destituido el artículo 115 de la
constitución peruana reza que es el
vicepresidente quien debe asumir las
funciones lo que significa que diana
baluarte sería quien tomaría la jefatura
del estado todos los presidentes que han
pasado por el poder en perú en los
últimos 36 años se han visto envueltos
en acusaciones de corrupción y tan sólo
en 2020 el mandatario martín vizcarra
fue destituido del poder por recepción
de sobornos